hey what's going on guys it's Rob yes
I'm still alive and kicking and I hope
you all had a wonderful Thanksgiving and
got to eat a whole bunch of Turkey yams
mashed potatoes cranberry and all that
good stuff I'd like to first of all
thank you all for being so supportive
for sticking with me I know it hasn't
been easy waiting for me to get videos
out for like you know months this is
going to be a quick update video school
has been pretty tough for me you know
I'm trying to get get out of school
basically I am in my last year of dental
school for those of you who don't know
and I'm just trying to get some
requirements done and I'm hopefully on
course to graduate this summer as you
can see the view in the background is
kind of different from my other videos
you know we had a little bit of flooding
this is actually the basement of my
house it's pretty empty right now you
could hear like an echo almost we had to
move furniture out because of Hurricane
sandy we had some flooding so we're just
getting some renovations done I recently
went down to Jamaica about a month ago I
believe and I do have some footage from
that trip that I'd like to show you guys
but besides that there's been some
tutorials that I've been meaning to
teach one of them is the shoe-tying
video I know a lot of you guys are like
well I already know how to tie my shoes
but I don't think you know how to do the
ninja not aka Ian's not which was
invented by Ian feegan and it is the
world's fastest shoelace tying knot now
there are some tutorials out there on
YouTube obviously it's been out for
years but of course I'd like to give
this shot and give it a little bit of my
personal spin to it if you guys don't
know what that is I like to just quickly
grab my shoe and I'll show you why it's
so cool so basically when you do the
regular knot you're doing something like
this either you're doing you know bunny
ears and you're wrapping that around and
tying it or you're doing the kind of
loop around and pull but the ninja knot
once you have this initial not here
you're taking it and you're just going
like this and that's that now
I'm not going to show how it's done in
this video I just wanted to show you
guys that this is something that I would
love to teach you guys because it's
really cool and it has changed the way
that I tie my shoes one other thing that
I like to show you guys how to make is
this it is extremely simple to make I've
known how to do this for years and it's
actually really fun and it is really
loud it is the paper popper it's very
simple you just need one sheet of paper
and all you got to do is basically take
it in your hand that's supposed to
happen that lets you know that it's a
little bit too tight but you can
basically adjust it here I also have
some paper planes that I know how to
make I think the paper popper I can
definitely do on Saturday like today or
tomorrow whenever this video comes out I
want to see what you guys think I'd like
to give you the pot the paper popper I
think it's really cool leave me a
comment in the comments section let me
know which of those you would like to
see the most and also I have comment
rating turned on so basically you can
leave a comment and also if you agree
with someone else's comment just give it
a thumbs up you guys know how that works
and i'd like to get a tutorial out by
tomorrow by saturday if possible alright
so it was good seeing you guys again and
I will see you again soon bye like